The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Thanks for coming.
I know there's a
problem set due.
There's a quiz coming
up on Thursday.
We won't have
lecture on Thursday.
But we will have a
quiz in the evening.
And there will be a
recitation section tomorrow,
which will be a quiz review.
So, today's lecture is the last
of the lectures in the shortest
path module.
And, unlike previous
lectures, we're
going to be talking about
optimizations that don't change
the worst case, or
asymptotic, complexity.
But improve empirical,
real life performance.
Or potentially, and we can't
prove this, but performance
in the average case.
And so we look at a
couple of examples.
The first one
you've already done.
You can optimize
Dijkstra when you're
looking for a single target.
So, implicitly, we've
assumed that we're
solving the single source, any
or all destination problem,
when we've looked at
the original Dijkstra
algorithm, and the
Bellman-Ford algorithm.
Many a time, you're going
to have a source, s.
And you want to find
the shortest path
to a specific destination, t.
And you're doing this
in your problem set.
And you can do
some optimization.
It doesn't change the
worst case complexity.
But it reduces runtime.
And then you have
a specific target.
Especially if the
target is close to you.
And you don't have to
traverse the entire graph.
Obviously, the
algorithm has to prove
that the particular
path that was chosen
is, in fact, the shortest
path from s to t.
But it's a fairly
straightforward modification.
And I will go over it,
but you're actually
implementing it in PS 6.
We talked about
bi-directional search.
Again, something you're
doing from a standpoint
of breadth-first search.
How can you get from one
source to a destination,
by doing bi-directional
Dijkstra?
And you can think of this as
a frontier off shortest paths
is being constructed from
the source, s, forward.
And this backward frontier,
you're falling edges backward,
is being constructed
from the destination.
And, effectively, when
these two frontiers meet,
you're going to be able to
discover shortest paths.
And, it turns out, it's not
as simple as what I just
described.
And so we'll have to look at
that a little more carefully.
So that is our single source,
single target problem.
We won't cover this in 006.
But there's also this notion of
all pairs shortest paths, which
is something that 6046 covers.
And that is something
that says, well, I
don't know what the source is.
I don't know what
the destination is.
For any pair of vertices,
find me the shortest path
from s to t, given that pair.
And so that, of
course, is more work
than even the single source,
all destination problem
because you're
varying the source.
All right?
So those are the three different
shortest path problems.
And we've looked at that.
And we're going to
look at this today.
And we looked at it
in the problem set.
But we'll spend time,
specifically on this one.
And try and see if we can do
some coding optimizations,
if you will, to
improve run time.
All right?
So, I emphasize that
worst case complexity
is unchanged for all of
the Dijkstra versions
that we'll be looking at today.
So I want to put up a pseudocode
that you've written code
for at this point, which
is the Dijkstra pseudocode.
Because we'll take a look at it,
and modify it, and execute it.
So you have your set
of vertices that you
don't know the
shortest paths to.
So we do have initialize is
going to set d of s to be 0.
And b of u, not equal
to s, to be infinity.
And we have this
set, Q, that we're
going to process and continually
extract the minimum priority
from Q. And, once we
do that, we actually
know the shortest
path to you already.
That's what the
Dijkstra invariant is.
And the process of
extracting u implies
that we have to do a
relaxation step that
updates the priorities.
And also modifies
the parent pointers.
So there's also the pi
of v that is set to u.
As well as d of v
getting decremented.
OK?
So that's the
Dijkstra algorithm.
And one of the things
that we can do,
the straightforward thing, which
is one line of code literally,
is to say that, if you know
what the single target is, then
you simply stop if u equals t.
So no need to stop
when Q becomes null.
Or, you don't get to the
point where Q is null.
You stop when you've lifted off
the y vertex from Q. All right?
And so, obviously,
this will run faster,
assuming this check
is a 0 time check.
And that's really
one instruction,
so you can think of it that way.
And you will, basically,
run faster for sure,
when you have a specific target.
It may be the case that your
target is the last vertex
that you find.
And in that case,
you run no slower.
All right?
So that's something
that you looked at.
And that takes care of the
first optimization corresponding
to single source, single target.
Let's talk about
something that's
a little more interesting,
and non-obvious,
which is the notion of
bi-directional search.
And, in bi-directional
search, we have s.
And we have t.
And we have a bunch
of nodes in between,
corresponding to
this graph here.
And what you do is,
you alternate search
in the forward direction
and backward direction.
So, you're going to do one step
of Dijkstra, standard Dijkstra
that starts with s.
And goes forward.
And so, you could imagine
that you're forward
search in the first step, you're
going to pick the vertex, s,
off of Q. And you're
going to process
the edges that come out of s.
And that would correspond
with these two edges.
And so that's one step of
forward search, going forward.
And then you stop with
the forward search,
and you do a step
of backward search.
And so, you go backward
search, and I'll
explain exactly what this
means, backward search from t.
And the important
thing is that you're
following edges backward.
So that means your
data structure
has to, essentially, have these
edges that can be traversed
in either the forward direction,
or the reverse direction.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
But what will happen
here is simply
that your first frontier
of backward search,
t now, in the backward search,
is the minimum priority.
So , we're going to have to have
two priorities corresponding
to s in the fourth search, where
that's a straightforward one.
v of s equals 0.
And we should think of
it as d of f s equals 0.
And we have d of b t equals 0.
And these subscripts
correspond to these two
different priorities.
And it's exactly complimentary.
Only the source, s,
in the forward search,
has 0 priority in the beginning.
Everything else has
infinite priority.
Only the target,
or destination, has
0 priority in the
backward search.
Everything else is infinity.
And you go forward,
backward, forward, backward.
And so on.
And the question is,
when do you stop?
And we have to talk about that.
And, it turns out, it's not
a perfectly straightforward
stopping condition.
But it's something that
will make sense, hopefully,
when I get around
to describing it.
But, having said
all that, let's just
put down all of the
different data structures
that we have to have.
And it's kind of a doubling
of the data structure,
right, because just like
I double the priorities,
I also need two
different min priority
queues, corresponding
to Q f and Q b.
And, as I said
before, these edges
have to be traversable in
the backward direction.
So this edge, in the
graph, goes this way.
But you're going in
the backward direction,
as you are growing
your backward frontier.
OK?
That's important to understand.
So let me put down all of
the specifics associated
with these data structures.
df u correspond to the distances
for the forward search.
And db u correspond
to the distances
for the backward search.
OK?
And, of course,
we're going to have
to have priority queues, plural.
Qf corresponding to
the forward search.
And Qb corresponding
to the backward search.
And in initialize,
as I said before,
we're going to initialize df
s to be 0 and db t equals 0.
And then everything, the
df's and the db's, are
going to be infinity.
All right?
OK.
Great.
So that's what we have here.
Now, first question.
Roughly speaking, as I said,
you can imagine intuitively
that you're going to
terminate the search when
these frontiers meet, OK?
Clearly, you can't
terminate it when
these frontiers
look like this, OK.
So that's the intuition.
And you see that
for the [INAUDIBLE]
first, as well, in
your problem set.
But in the context of Dijkstra,
single source, single target,
can someone tell me what
the termination condition
should be by
looking at the code?
I want a more specific,
or a more concrete,
termination condition that
I can actually code up,
as opposed to saying,
the frontiers meet.
Which, you know, I
don't know how to code.
OK?
Someone else?
All right, go for it.
AUDIENCE: When
there's some node that
can keep track of two
different cost values from--
PROFESSOR: The Qf and
the Qb, that's correct.
And, somehow--
AUDIENCE: Somehow
they're cost runs
to get there from the start
and from the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
It's close.
It's not quite
something I can code up.
Someone want to improve that?
I want something
very, very specific.
Someone?
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: The node has been
extracted from both Qf and Qb.
PROFESSOR: The
node which has been
extracted from both Qf and Qb.
So, the reason I didn't
quite buy your answer
was, finite part is
obviously correct.
But I wanted a
specific condition
that says, I'm going
to do extract-min,
just like I said when I
extract-min and u equals t,
I stop with the single
source, single target.
In the bi-directional
case, I need
to pull out a node from Qf.
And pull out a node from Qb.
And then I get to
stop, all right?
So, you get a cushion.
You don't need to
feel too bad because I
think you already
have a cushion.
Yeah.
I know that.
I know everyone
who has cushions.
Right.
Actually, I don't.
But I'm going to pretend I do.
So, the termination condition
is that some vertex, and this is
correct, some vertex,
u, has been processed,
both in the forward search
and the backward search.
OK?
That corresponds to
the frontiers meeting.
But, specifically,
it's been deleted,
or extracted from
both Qf and Qb.
So that's actually
the easier question.
Visit a harder question, which
is how do we find the shortest
path after termination
from s to t?
OK?
And I should say specifically,
that-- and I forgot
to put this up, which
I should-- that we're
going to have to have
pi f and pi b, which
this is the normal
data structure.
And the pi b is following
the edges backward.
So, in some sense,
the predecessor,
in the case of pi b, what
you're saying is, on this node
here-- which I'll
call v2 for example--
is, if I'm going to
choose this path here--
and I need to obviously choose
this edge here in any shortest
path that gets to t, right?
Because that's the only
edge that goes to t.
And so, what I'm saying here
is that a predecessor of pi b t
equals v2.
OK?
That make sense?
And then over here,
if this was v1,
then I would have
pi f v1 equals s.
Right?
That make sense?
Everybody buy that?
All right, so how do I find
the shortest path from s to t,
after these frontiers have met,
and I've terminated the search?
How do I do that?
Someone?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, given that data
structure, you start at your t.
And you keep on going
back to the [INAUDIBLE]
until you get to the point
where they've peaked.
Then you use the pi f
to go from that node,
all the way back to s.
PROFESSOR: So, what
I'm going to have to do
is-- but where do I
switch, is the question.
Where do I switch
from pi f to pi b?
There has to be some point where
I switch from-- Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: At the meeting
point of the node
that was [INAUDIBLE]
Q [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
Is that what you
were saying, too?
OK.
So the claim is, if w was
processed first, extracted
from both Qf and Qb, then find
the shortest path using pi
f from s to w.
Right?
So, you can use pi f
to get from s to w.
And the way you do that
is by applying pi f to w.
And then keep applying it
until you get to s, OK?
This is normal search, right?
Everybody knows this.
You coded it.
So I hope you know it.
And then, we go find shortest
path using pi b, right?
And you're going
to constantly apply
pi b-- and this is the
backward path-- from t to w.
And this follows the
edges backward, all right?
This sounds pretty good?
Everybody agree with this?
Anybody disagree?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Pi b.
If [INAUDIBLE], pi b would
be like pi b b2 equals t,
because b2 [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
I might have done this wrong.
So, in the backward search,
this can get pretty confusing.
So what do I have here?
I want to follow
the predecessor.
You're exactly right.
Thank you.
Thank you for pointing that out.
All right, so what
I have here is
when I look at this path that
goes this way, all right?
I'm going to look at the
path that goes this way.
s is the predecessor of v1.
v1 is a predecessor
of, let's call this v3.
v3 is a predecessor of v4.
I'm just talking about
the regular forward path.
We have s to v1.
v1 to v3.
v3 to v4.
All the way to t, right?
So what I have here is correct.
The predecessor of v1 is s.
The predecessor
of v3 would be v1.
So I could write,
pi f v3 equals v1.
Et cetera.
Now, let's just forget about
the forward path, and let's
just talk about
the backward path.
In the backwoods
path, I want to be
able to construct
this backward path.
It's got to be the reverse
of what I have, OK?
And, in that case,
what I'm saying
is that I want to move
in this direction.
So pretend that I've
made the edges flip, OK?
So, in that case, if I pretend
that this edge is like that,
and then I just apply
the regular predecessor
relationship, then t is
the predecessor of v2.
And that's the
point you're making.
OK? t is the predecessor of v2.
And so, my apologies.
I have pi b v2 equals t.
And, if I follow this
edge here, then I'd
have the appropriate
relationship.
But let's just stick to
this one because that's
the simple example.
I don't quite know
whether this edge
is going to be part of
my shortest path or not.
It might be.
And that's something
that we'll compute.
But what I have here is the
predecessor relationship
corresponding to
the backward edge.
And so, that's like
flipping this edge.
And, hopefully, that
makes sense now.
Thanks for pointing that out.
And so, let's talk
about what happens here.
We know what happens
in the forward search.
You've done that before.
In the backward
search, what happens
is that I need to start--
according to this condition--
just like in the forward
search, I found a w.
And I continually
applied pi of f to w.
So, this is apply pi of f to w.
And then do pi of f pi of f w.
And so on and so forth.
And that's what you do in order
to construct the shortest path.
People buy that?
Right?
And what I want to do
here is apply pi b to w.
And then, pi b of pi b to w.
And so on and so
forth, till I get to t.
Right?
And this one, till I get to s.
So, what I wrote
here, s to w, t to w.
There's nothing
incorrect about that.
What's important to understand
is the application of the pi
f and the pi b.
Both, according to
this, start with w,
which is this vertex that caused
the termination to happen.
All right?
So, people buy this?
Any other questions?
All right.
Turns out this is
not quite correct.
OK?
This is not quite
correct, right?
And not because of the pi b
inversion that I had before,
right?
So what have I said, so far?
It makes perfect sense.
It says, I have a vertex
that caused the termination.
I'm going to call it w.
OK?
And that vertex is on the
intersection of these two
frontiers, OK?
And I'm going to use that
to construct the shortest
path by constructing
two sub paths,
using the forward pointers
and the backward pointers.
All right?
So all of that
makes sense except,
it turns out, that w may
not be on the shortest path.
OK?
And I'll show you
an example where
w is not on the shortest path.
All right?
So that's at a real
subtle condition.
So we have to actually augment
the termination condition.
Or, we have to do something more
than the termination condition.
So, I will tell you right
away, the termination condition
is correct.
OK?
And so, the guy who got the
cushion, deserved the cushion.
OK?
So the termination
condition as correct.
You are going to run Dijkstra
's ultimate forward search
and backward search.
And you're going to terminate
when a particular vertex, call
it w, is going to get pulled
out from both Qf and Qb.
All right?
What is incorrect
here is the use of w
to construct the shortest path.
All right?
It turns out, we have
to do a little more work
to go find the shortest
path, after we've terminated.
And w may not be on
the shortest path.
All right?
Any ideas as to
what we might do?
This is a bit of
an unfair question,
but certainly worth a cushion.
How do you think
we can fix this?
If w is not on
the shortest path,
what do you think would
be on the shortest path?
Is there a way of
finding this vertex,
so we can break this up?
We absolutely have to
use both pi f and pi b.
There's no getting
away from that
because these two frontiers
have just barely collided.
The instant they barely
collided, we've stopped.
OK?
So we can't use pi f
all the way from s to t.
We can't use pi b all
the way from t to s.
These frontiers have
just barely collided.
OK?
So what happens if w is
not on the shortest path?
And why is that the case?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just had a question.
Are all the edge
weights identical?
Or are they--
PROFESSOR: So, the edge
weights don't change.
There are no new edges.
The way you want
to think about is
that, you can traverse
the edges backward.
And so, it's not like
there are two edges here.
Now, you could fake
it, and have two edges
with exactly the same
weights over here.
But are you saying there are
edge weights in the graph,
all identical across the edges?
Or are you asking about
the forward search
versus the backward search?
AUDIENCE: That's
what I was asking.
Is each edge weight
the same in the graph.
PROFESSOR: No.
They're using Dijkstra.
The edge ways can be arbitrary.
But they're non-negative.
OK?
So that's the usual
Dijkstra requirement.
They could be real numbers.
They could be
irrational numbers.
They could be whatever.
But they're all non-negative.
All right?
Now, in the backward search
and the forward search-- just
to make that clear-- while I've
drawn this particular edge,
that weight hasn't changed, OK?
That weight had
better be the same.
OK?
All right, so I'll
show you an example.
And we'll take an example, a
fairly straightforward example,
it turns out.
It took a while to
concoct this five node
example that shows
the idea here.
But what we're going to do is,
take a look at the termination
condition in a
specific case, where
we're going to do this
alternation of forward
and backward search.
And we'll see,
when it terminates,
as to what the correct way is
to construct the shortest path.
All right?
And, as I said before,
the termination condition
is correct.
It's not like we stop too early.
When one of those nodes
gets off from Qf and Qb,
you get to stop.
So that's my s, over here.
And I have a fairly
straightforward graph.
I have 5, 5, 3, 3, 3.
So we don't need
a computer program
to tell us that the
shortest path from s to t
is the path with three
edges that goes on top, OK,
which has a weight of 9.
All right.
So this is a forward search.
And I'm going to call all
of these vertices names.
So I have u prime.
t. et cetera.
OK?
So, in the first step
of the forward search,
I'm going to be able
to set-- oh, I'm sorry.
This one is a w.
I'm going to be able
to set df w equals 5.
And df u equals 3.
And, obviously,
df of s equals 0.
And I'm not going to bother
writing the infinities.
It's just going to clutter
up the board, all right?
So, stop me if you have
questions on anything
I'm writing here.
So that's a forward search.
Now, let's do the first step
of backward search, right?
Alternate, remember?
Alternate forward
search, backward search,
forward search, backward search.
And I'm just going to
write this out again,
so bear with me,
because I think it'd
be clearer if you see
this graph many times.
As opposed to my erasing
what I've written.
So I've got an s, here.
t there.
u.
u prime.
w.
And I'm going to hash
this vertex vertically
because that's my
backward search.
And db of t equals 0.
OK?
And I'm going to follow this
backward, and this backward.
And my weights are the same.
It's the same graph.
So I'm going to have d
of b u prime equals 3.
And db of w equals 5.
And I haven't seen u yet.
I haven't seen s yet.
And so, all I've done
is mark these two.
All right?
So far, so good?
Again, stop me if
you have questions.
We've got, obviously, a
couple more steps to go here.
And let's keep going.
So now we do a
forward search again.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's this hash that
way, just to make sure.
This is s, u, u prime, w, t.
And what I have
now is, I'm going
process this vertex
in the forward search
because I have a choice
to either pick w or w.
This clearly has lower
priority because df w equals 5.
And df of u equals 3.
So extract-min is
obviously going to pick u.
And it's going to process this
edge now, after extract-min.
And I'm going have df
of u prime equals 6.
OK?
AUDIENCE: It's 3 over there.
PROFESSOR: Oh,
it's 3 over there.
Thanks.
Good.
So, so far, so good?
Yeah?
All right.
So now, I go to the
backward search.
And again, I have
s, t, u, u prime, w.
I'm going to go
ahead and hash this.
This has been
hashed horizontally.
The hash horizontally means
that it's been removed from Qf.
The hash vertically means that
it's been removed from Qb.
And so, when I look at this,
and I do a backward search,
I'm going to hash this.
And I'm going to set
db of u prime equals 3.
And I have db of w equals 5.
So, that I already had.
And so, when I have db of w
equals 5 and db of u prime
equals 3, then,
obviously, I'm going
to pick the one with
the min priority.
This corresponds to this one.
And what it's going
to do is, it's
going to go process that
and set db of u equals 6.
All right?
So what happened here simply was
that I picked this vertex off
of Qb because that
was the min priority.
And all I did was relax
this particular edge
in the backward direction.
And said db u equals 6.
All right?
Almost there.
Any questions so far?
Any bugs you noticed so
far, in what I've written?
Yeah, back there, question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
So people agree with this.
All right, one more.
One more board to draw.
And we'll be done.
We will have terminated.
All right, so
getting pretty close.
So I'm set up this way.
Oh, shoot.
Sorry.
This is horizontal.
So, now I'm looking at it, and
I've taken care of these two.
And I'm talking about
the forward search here.
So this is, again, the forward.
And that's the backward.
And now I'm doing
a forward again.
And my only choice, now, is to
pick the w vertex off of Qf.
Right?
Because df w equals 5.
And this one has
already been processed.
df of u equals 3.
But I've hashed that.
And so I've gone ahead
and processed that vertex.
And this one, df of
u prime equals 6.
So, in Qf, I would be
comparing u prime and w.
And I would take w, OK?
People buy that?
That's because, I guess you by
the fact that 5 is less than 6.
I hope.
So that's what happens in
the step of forward search.
And then you go ahead
and process this.
You're going to set
df of t to be 10.
OK?
And now you're
starting to see why
there may be a bit of a
problem with our shortest path
computation, right?
Maybe.
All right?
Everything good?
All right.
So what have I done here?
I've removed w from Qf.
OK.
All right.
Now, let's look at the last step
here, of the backward search.
s, t.
And so, this was hashed.
That was hashed.
And, if I look at
what I have here,
I have db u prime equals 3.
df u prime equals 6.
This was df w equals 5.
db w equals 5.
And so on and so forth.
Again, you compare w.
And you see that db w equals 5.
And df u prime equals 6.
So therefore, you will pick w.
OK?
You will pick w, and
remove it from Qf.
So remove w from Qf.
All right?
And process it.
And what you end up with
is df of s equals 10.
OK?
That's what you get
because this is a 5.
And that's a 5.
OK?
People see the problem here?
What's the problem?
Someone articulate the problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I mean, so, what I have so
far is, I've terminated.
But it looks like I
end up with d of s.
If I look at it
from a standpoint
of the forward weight,
I got a 10 for t.
I get db t equals 10.
If I look from a standpoint
of the backward weight,
I get db s equals 10.
OK?
And we all know that the
shortest path should be 9.
OK.
So what happened here?
Well, we terminated
according to this condition.
We terminated when w was
pulled off from Qf and Qb
because that was the
short path, in some sense,
in terms of number
of edges, right?
It was only of length 2.
And so, then the
frontiers collide.
This is a subtlety
in the algorithm.
The frontiers collide
at some vertex,
regardless of the
weights of the edges.
Because we are alternating
the forward search
and the backward
search, in effect,
the frontiers are going to
collide on the shortest length
path.
Right?
That makes sense, right?
So this example is set up so
the shortest length path is not
the shortest weight path.
OK?
So we can't take the w
and use pi f to construct
part of the path, and
use pi b to construct
the other part of the path.
And find the
shortest weight path.
We would get
something incorrect.
Right?
We would get a path of
length 10, in this case,
if we did that.
So how do we fix it?
How do we fix it?
One little termination
condition doesn't change.
How do we fix it?
Someone?
Back there.
Or, actually, you.
AUDIENCE: Ordinate
based on the weight.
PROFESSOR: Ordinate
So exactly how would we do that?
AUDIENCE: At each
point you take the one
that has the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But that's what
we're doing now, right?
So, are you changing
the alternation
between the forward search
and the backward search?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: You're
saying that you're
going to do more forward
searches, as opposed
to backward searches?
AUDIENCE: If the
overall cost is lower.
PROFESSOR: Overall
cost is lower.
You know, if you code it
up, you get to keep this.
If I want a slightly
different, simpler
fix because I think what
you're saying here--
and I like the idea.
I actually do like the idea.
You're saying you're going
to not do strict alternation.
But you're going to do some
sort of weighted alternation,
from what I can tell,
based on the weights.
OK?
And I think there's an
algorithm there that's correct.
OK?
I probably won't
be able to prove
that it's correct to
myself in five minutes.
OK.
Or 10 minutes.
But let's talk
about that offline.
And see if there's a way.
I'm a little
worried that, if you
have positive rational
numbers, and you've
got root 2, square
root of 2, and pi.
And the transcendental number
corresponding to these weights,
that this weighted
alternation is
going to be a bit hard
to implement correctly.
But it's a neat idea.
I would actually like
a follow up on that.
Something that's a
little-- yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: Can you look at the
neighbors of all the nodes that
are in your forward
[INAUDIBLE], and see
if any of their neighbors
are in backwards [INAUDIBLE].
And see if that's going to give
you a shorter path than the one
that you pulled out previously.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
That's almost exactly correct.
I won't bother throwing it
over, but this is yours.
You want to catch it?
AUDIENCE: I already have one.
PROFESSOR: You already
have a cushion.
All right.
So how about I just throw it.
And anybody who wants
to catch it gets it.
How's that?
Whoa.
All right.
I didn't hit anybody.
Anybody who wants it, who
doesn't have a cushion.
Right.
We've got all these cushions in
my office, and Eric's office.
We've got to do
something about them.
They're actually not that great.
You know, it's bit of
an issue, I understand.
You know, we've got to
do Frisbees next time,
or something.
I can see why you're not
enthusiastic about this.
Right?
OK.
All right, so the answer
was, in fact, correct.
And let me write
it up over here.
So we had to do a
little more work.
We terminate properly.
We do the strict alternation.
But we have to do a
little bit more work.
OK.
And the work we have to do
is summarized very neatly
by saying, we want to
find an x, which is maybe
different from w,
possibly, that has
minimum value of
d of x plus db x.
All right?
So we have to actually look.
And this x is going
to be neighboring.
But we don't really
need to specify that.
What we say is, you're going
to have to look at Qf and Qb.
And it's possible
that w is the one that
has minimum df w plus db w.
But, clearly, that wasn't
the case in this example.
So, in this example, w
caused the termination.
But now we need to scan.
And there's only
two other vertices
that are interesting here,
which are u and u prime.
And either of those
will fit the bill
because we see that df of u
plus db of u equals 3 plus 6
equals 9.
And df of u prime plus db of
u prime equals-- I'm sorry,
I should have out db here.
db of u prime would
be 6 plus 3 equals 9.
Right?
So both of these
are less than 10.
And so we had to pick
one of these as our x.
OK.
And if you pick one of these
as our x, then, at that point,
we don't do w here.
We do x.
OK?
Let me write it as x.
It looks like a cross here.
So that's what happens.
So this small little tweak.
Do the alternation.
Do the termination.
Once you do the
termination, go look
and see if you can
minimize the shortest path
length by finding
an appropriate x.
Which has the minimum sum of
the forward and the backward
priorities.
And then, you're in business.
And then, everything works.
OK?
All right.
Great.
So, so much for
bi-directional search.
Let me talk a little
bit about heuristics
that people use to modify the
graph so things run faster
in practice.
So, in particular, you can think
about the goal directed search,
or a star, if
you're taking 6034.
And there's some
commonality between what
I'm going to talk about
here, and that material.
The basic idea is
that we're going
to modify the edge
weights in such a way
that you go downhill
toward the shortest path.
And so, the priorities are
modified heuristically.
So things run a
little bit quicker.
You're trying to
prune the search here.
So we're going to
modify edge weights.
And we have to be careful
when we do this, obviously.
We don't want to do
things that are incorrect.
But the way we want to
modify the edge weights
is by having some sort
of potential function
that corresponds to lambda.
And, if the edge
is between u and v,
then we have an equation
given a lambda that says,
the new w, w bar, is w u, v
minus lambda u plus lambda
v. OK?
Now, we have to be a little
careful here, with respect
to the choice of lambda.
But the basic idea,
in terms of lambda,
is that, suppose you
have something like this,
where you have a
source vertex, s.
And you're again trying
to do a single source,
single target going to t.
And let's say I have an
edge of weight 5 going out
and an edge of a 5
going out this way.
Is there a way
that you can guess
that this is the
edge that is more
likely to be on
your shortest path?
As opposed to this other edge?
Essentially increase
the potential
of this node, all right?
So this node here
may be the node t2.
And this node may
be the node t1.
You want to increase the
potential of node t2,
such that, you're
actually trying
to go uphill when
you go this way.
And this goes downhill.
And that has the
appropriate modifications
on the edge weights, such
that the Dijkstra algorithm is
steered towards going downhill.
And going down this path.
And it terminates a
little bit quicker.
Right?
It doesn't change as
asymptotic complexity.
It just makes things run, in
practice, a little bit faster.
If you choose the
right potentials.
Right?
Feels like magic.
How do you know how to
increase the potential?
What would you increase
the potential for?
What nodes do you
want to make uphill?
want to make downhill?
So there's a bunch of questions.
I'm not going to get
into a lot of details.
But I will tell you
a couple of things.
I'm going to give you, really
quickly, a simple example
that is both correct, in terms
of the actual shortest path you
will get is the correct one.
And a particular
mechanism off modifying
the potentials that
uses landmarks.
Right.
So the way we are
going to do this
is by saying that
any path wp is going
to get modified based on
its destination and source.
So the only way that we can
use the potential method
is by ensuring that
all of the shortest
paths between any pair
of vertices, we're
only concerned about single
source, single target here.
But, in general,
it's a good thing
to not change any of
the shortest paths.
So what used to
be a shortest path
should stay the shortest path.
And the way you do
that is by having
a potential function that,
if you have an arbitrary
path, essentially-- and
this is a path from s to t.
That you subtract
out something based
on a function of the vertex.
In this case, you have s.
And, in this case, you have t.
So the nice thing is
that, any path from s to t
is going to get shifted by
the same amount, corresponding
to this additional term here.
So what that means is
that the final shortest
path that you discover will
be the correct shortest path.
You just may, hopefully,
discover it faster.
All right?
So that's the correctness check.
And I'll put this in the notes.
And maybe the TAs can
cover it in the section.
But one way of getting
this potential function
is to use what's
called a landmark.
And so the basic idea is
that you have a landmark, l,
which is a vertex
belonging to v.
And we're going to pre-compute
delta of u comma l.
So, for any input
vertex, you want
to find the shortest
path to this landmark.
So it's like, change the
source, but the destination
stays the same.
And the potential
lambda t u is defined
as delta of u, l
minus delta of t, l.
OK?
So you have the source, s.
You have a destination, t.
And now you have a landmark, l.
I'm going to pre-compute delta
u,l for all u belonging to v.
And I'm also going to
pre-compute, for a given t,
delta t, l.
So that's just a single t.
So that's just one computation.
This one is much
more computation.
And, if I use this potential,
you can show that it's correct,
using the triangle inequality.
And this is not a heuristic.
With the correct
choice of landmark,
Dijkstra, empirically,
will run faster.
So, if you know
for sure that you
need to go through middle
America to get from Cal Tech
to Boston-- and there's
one particular landmark
you want to go through--
Texas or something.
And you pick Austin, Texas, then
you can do this computation.
And maybe Dijkstra runs
2x faster, 20% faster.
All right?
I'll put the argument about
correctness, and the specifics
of these things, in the notes.
And you can take a
look at it offline.